hello hi donya how are you doing he's
not entertaining
hi andrea i am doing great oh okay
how are you oh sorry about that no no
problem
um how are you going i am doing great
very well prepared for today
i am intimidated as usual by these words
of course
well donna are you uh willing to put
something on the line for today or are
you not feeling confident
i am always willing to put something on
the line always that's what we like to
hear
send you a video on facebook tell me if
you're down to do that dance if you lose
it's odd it's not anything else
okay um just check it
and tell me if you're willing to put
that on the line uh
it's a little funny
that is an interesting one maybe i'm
willing to do it in
perhaps a slightly more toned down
version it could be it could be the best
as your best effort
just a silly dance like this person
looks like a candle you know
this person likes yeah absolutely but i
won't have to do it because
because i'll win so always win so you
won't have to do it but if you lose you
just have to give your best effort
you don't have to learn it you just have
to watch it once or twice and then do
your best chance
okay that's all and i have to do it to
to britney's fear is toxic
uh no because you'll get banned yeah no
no no i i think you have to play
non-copyright music and just have the
video on your stream
and just do your best
[Music]
only issues can you reach them okay
there's a lot on the line there's a
dance on the line and
honestly i'm not in the mood to dance so
i better just win
yeah all right all right here we go
ready set go okay
and i hope you guys see the game i mean
okay so i'm going to make a move and
then i'm going to wait until 40 seconds
what are you waiting for for 40 seconds
andrea
focus on the game let's do this okay i
think that's fair
so this is what i usually play yep nice
clean okay i love it i don't know if
it's bishop or knife bishop b7 looks
clean here
ship c4 i think it was united
white is slightly better in these
positions b5 bishop b3
no pretty much what the key is going to
be zero pre-moving
solid chess and i believe in my ability
to win time pressure situation i
the mistake that i usually make is i
play way too fast in the opening i get a
lost position and then i try to come
back from it
i mean a4 was better here but it's okay
we didn't allowing this is not such a
big deal
b492
[Music]
yes wait but now when he does this
oh we should have uh it should be five
yeah
he just goes there white is better
i should have played this they are
taking their sweet time here that's what
we want to see
so this and this i would do that anyway
these ones are bad we do that
yeah yeah and then if rookies
i think d6 is good e6 i can go g4 and
maybe win the bishop
and then you push and then we take it
for free
no the night oh yeah yeah we have two
nights yeah
our tactics are again
um i don't know if there is
a way out here
he only has 30 seconds okay we have a
minute
back to e5 they're gonna go knight d7
all right what am i going to do bishop
b5
that's a free rook okay well let's try
to fly okay now we don't want to get
checkmated obviously
david david up to d6
oh knight c5 was better but it's fine i
can go here queen f5 will just go queen
e4 i don't want to risk
actually i can just take the rook she
they've got no check on on g5 so
queen takes okay rook d6 yeah i can
maybe go here this is easier because i
take this guy
okay green f5 i'll just take it and win
with upper rook hopefully
now i can remove this guy you're doing
well 94
[Music]
nothing new here
all right good game okay excellent that
was pretty smooth i think the opening
[Music]
more like three days two days i'm gonna
disable the alerts guys sorry about that
in advance
i haven't done anything with my hair i
i've been i haven't liked it all right
okay all right here we go
no yes i'm going to play the london
probably let's go nice let's just go c5
i want to unbalance it
d5 just get something very sharp
with the black pieces tonight it has to
be knight here or is it a four
a four i think i don't know but we can't
decide you think
a4 is fun and now okay you play i don't
know slime he's not letting us play the
london
okay c4 i'll go d6 and g6 um bishop out
maybe dark squared this one we can
basically start removing
okay okay slow down a little bit no need
to speed here
rookie and e5 is going to be the next
two moves
regardless of what they do i like e4 e4
because then you can retreat to e3 e4
35 seconds i've wasted already five
that's not acceptable
right
[Music]
wait can we take no we can't um
a5 queen c6 takes takes let's
yeah let's take with the bishop and then
on the next move i'll play queen c6
and now this f5 is a threat if they go
f3
i'll just go rook d8 and bring the rook
into the game
and then i'll go f5 maybe at the right
moment and sack on f3
well rookie gotten good
if they move their king i have knight d2
winning the queen yeah you can actually
safely pre-move this
no actually king f1 that you'll play
then i'll go knight h2 so let's bring up
quinn takes f3
we have no choice but the issue is
bishop f
here yeah this is completely winning i
just got to be disciplined
let me play this then g5 is an idea here
just getting rid of this bishop so that
the rook can crash through
no threat on the queen i can always give
a check if they move the knight
and now we go g5
yep yep sensible defensive idea but
shouldn't be enough e8 and rook d3 i'll
go
ah okay let's just go here end it
f1 that was i had this on the previous
move that's just made it
made on the spot i mean i guess they
have i guess they do have this one yeah
16 seconds
and now we lose our order all right
oh man it was that stupid sack that was
bad technique but i got the job done
all right don't worry don't worry i need
like some
oh this is that was very close though
way too close i was way way way
way too close i'm ready i'm ready alex
this is the one
all right here we go
all right all right let's go
yep i'm scared
okay now they play the perk which they
don't even play that's good
no this is serious i'm just going to go
for the kill here
which is dangerous because if they know
what to do this is not a good move but
i'm going to trust my instincts so that
this is the right decision
i think they take and then push c5 all
right
c5 is very oh god man they know what
they're doing here
that was a bad idea should not have done
that but it's fine this is
still in okay position bishop g3 bishop
f2
yeah this is bad for white i mean i have
no idea why i went for this they're
they're now
like super strong
watch out for knight b5
knight
yeah yeah yeah yeah
knight c5 knight c4 knight c4
he's catching up everything okay okay
check what about this
no your queen oh it doesn't i want it no
no no no no queen
seven go queen yes yes yes yes and then
you take the pawn and you have nice
chest
thankfully i have this one they might be
too man
very precise play incredible now two
puns down in the end game will i win
this
c4 just professional play
i would think this is the gm isn't it
better okay d6 we just gotta confuse
them and
run their clock down somehow stay
blender f5 just wins i think
a five d e though maybe i'm holding on
for now
okay do it just so much time to
calculate
f4 wins oh my god this is ridiculous
i didn't realize how good they were i
guess now we push
yeah yeah yeah and then he's gonna sag
we went just got out played look up for
him
no i don't want to let him out you take
the knight i knew that i need to go for
still man
take the pawn yeah and then he loses the
rope do we have anything better because
he's almost done take the bomb
i always go for these ridiculous sides
never mind don't do it don't do it
you're chilling if he comes through the
pond we're gonna come for him
he does he does you burnt the chicken
roasted in beautiful yeah
she's crying beautiful
sorry chad we don't have good music i
mean there's just no chance
they played a perfect game
that was a beautiful game that was a
beautiful game
i mean i shouldn't go for these odds
there's no chance but congrats
i mean i don't know what you guys what i
would have expected from me
i've no i didn't know they were this
good
this is just incredible this is
incredible yeah i guess i have to do the
dance reaction
because he's so nice
he's always so nice man
oh i don't know what's expected of me i
think i did my best
we're just here sneaky thank you for the
20 gifted
the worst thing about beating dania is
you always feel a little bit bad because
he does you know he's like he's such a
good sport and then he's put in his best
effort
yeah i don't remember winning ever
winning a match against them i don't
remember when he ever went to the match
and maybe
i mean i think in the future what i
should do is we should have something
where like they have to get to a certain
number of points and i have to get to a
certain number of points because like
adopting them
is unfortunately just not possible uh
they're just too strong
winning ten in a row in with this time
brush is just just not possible but
i agree to it so
unfortunately it's just it's just not
not feasible at all
i don't know anyways it is fair i mean
we agreed to it
we could yeah no more adoption yeah
maybe well even yeah i don't i didn't
expect to
i mean honestly hey
[Applause]
but you're also too nice you're both too
good and too nice
i think we agree i think i think the
terms were quite clear quite clear
oh well we could do the dance and then
do one
redemption with maybe half the
amount of wins i think i think what we
need to do
i think what we should do is uh for the
next match maybe do something like i
have to still win nine and a half but i
get like you have to get to like three
points for example
for example yeah okay yeah yeah so you
have to get nine and a half before we
get
three yeah let's let's do that i think
that's i think that's
you know you know uh okay otherwise man
you're probably still thrashing me but
we're down to not count this one if you
want to do the next no no no we'll count
this one
we can we can maybe just play the next
match and then i'll do the dance or do
would you prefer that i do the dance now
yeah okay why don't we do the next the
same one so if we lose we'll also
do it yeah okay lose we'll do it if you
win you could even it out or we could
both do it you pick
all right you're very you're very
gracious but uh that sounds good
that sounds good we're gonna so we're
gonna start a new zero zero
you get nine and a half before we get
two enough
okay that's perfect that's perfect i
appreciate it appreciate it all right
good luck
best of luck all right good luck good
luck
good luck yeah that's painful but let's
see
i think this this time i have some
better chances thank you so much for the
10 gifted i really appreciate it thank
you guys yeah okay
the problem is you just make one tiny
inaccuracy and the game is immediately
over
he really does so it's fine yeah they're
very nice
they they they don't i mean i agree to
do the dance i'll do the dance i
honestly prefer to play for subs
rather than doing the dance foot i agree
to do it so i'll do it hey
no ideal is a deal so i will do the
dance guys please relax
but let's see hopefully i can get at
least some revenge
oh sorry okay all right
yeah they just played they played on the
gm level there was nothing i could have
done i shouldn't have gone for this
opening
i need to play more objectively in the
opening
i need to play more objectively in the
opening but um
once i made that once i've learned of
the pawn there was just no chances
all right let's focus wish me luck guys
i mean i think they just work together
very well like andrea sees the stuff
alexandra misses and alexander sees the
stuff andrea misses
that's how how cooperation works we have
to get two and a half
two players who are like 21 22 can
combine to be much stronger
if they complement each other's
weaknesses and strengths
so andrea has a very nice opening
repertoire very difficult to play
against london system he didn't punish
it okay
just complete buzz saw every game um
and alexandra is very good at spotting
tricks and tactics
andrea andrea's a very good positional
player so
together they they are basically able to
check most of the boxes
they're incredibly strong i mean i i
mean i know i'm always expected to adopt
the hell out of everybody including
magnus but you know
i mean give them a little bit of credit
guys i'm true i really am trying my best
here
they really are very strong together
i usually am the first one to crap on
myself but this time
these are difficult odds
um and here sure i don't think this is
very good
just when the expectations are always
for you to beat everybody all the time
they are kind of impossible to be honest
okay bring the rope
to e1 rook fc1 and bring it and then to
e3
let's go yes
rook rook pre-move
play that but then he's going to play
rook v8 no he can't yeah do it
do it no a4 i think i can do it if i can
get get them into the right
kinds of positions sure
i just think in the future we'll play
for subs that's the only lesson from
this
i definitely prefer gifting sub so we're
doing it bishop e5
and gate
[Music]
oh he did find a way to attack
yeah i didn't think he would um f3
no that's losing um i like f3
no because they just take and then what
and then
um maybe like i don't know it's kind of
bad now it might be over
well maybe rook d1 and then push c4 he
doesn't have that much
push c4 oh all right this is just
crashing after rook takes you too
we don't have a choice yeah
i think it's over you know what i'm
gonna try to play no no
okay we going into the end game was
really difficult and my bishop b5 idea
i thought it was good but i didn't
realize that thank you ray for the prime
okay the score is by our names it's fine
yeah but we have to start from where we
are going now
okay let's go for another perk i mean if
they repeat that line i just won't play
the
stupid h4 crap that i played the first
game assuming they want cc5
so i'll just play i'll just play kind of
normal theoretical line
all right guys it's just one game don't
get ahead of yourselves
all right oops sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry
i did not okay it's fine they said it
anyway i appreciate the primers
thank you raider i don't know how they
know the perk though because neither of
them plays it
but they know the theory okay okay it's
good now um yeah but that's the idiom
bishop d3 stuff
yeah this isn't my line don't try to
play my
is not correct openings uh sure nice
seat okay well we'll see how the
preparation goes
um thank you if i actually play theory
g4
this time i will actually play theory
rather than crap so
let's see how this goes queen
e6 and we have a roof on the file and a
very awkward bishop
what about just asic not better what's
so wrong and he's gonna take
sure you can trade queens but we are bad
in the end game
queen e4 maybe nice
okay g yep
look at d1 8 i mean
uh e no no no e6 no
not e6 [ __ ] take oh
yeah we we don't do well in the end game
against him
i haven't noticed
take check they don't have a choice
oh could you push b5 no because he has
knight h6
knight six yeah i just need to play
series simple as that cannot get a worse
position out of the opening
no no no b5 be five but why give a fun
for free it's not free
it's not free because no you know it's
good do it do it
and if he goes here
here no he tried to close remove the
king
here but our fc5 pawn is hanging
uh knight no h6 and then king here
and what's the difference uh he can't
take here
and now we play this
he's gonna take rook g1 wins the uh wins
the bishop
taking it five is kind of cool i don't
know what else to do other than try here
we might as well try yeah
[Music]
wait i don't think going to that game is
a good idea too okay
i think that's our he is much stronger
than ending i think adoption is
close to being fair but i think like
maybe two points is like fair
can we put on difference okay let's play
theory no more
garbage openings enough enough of that
real stuff yeah no real real stuff
that's one of the issues and andrea's
repertoire is really good
like legitimately really good it fits
her style so
those london systems especially just
cannot play this speculative stuff
thank you thank you thank you i need to
play more theoretical openings
let's go one second what
is there anything you need to answer
right now yeah
uh can we do it after the match yep okay
all right i will definitely do the dance
though i'm a man of my word
i do not give my word to that stuff and
then and then not do it
should i go for a c oh my god c3 is the
correct sorry
yeah but he's gonna do this boring game
we were playing i'm like i'm like so
used to just starting oops
i forgot okay
i started with three minutes i didn't
realize that i forgot about that
that we hadn't set the time
no just support just four alex abort
okay they're gonna do 38 seconds
38 38 seconds is what we're going to do
okay 36 that's fine
okay it's it's i don't know what the
dance is i mean alexander sent me a
tic-tac video
uh this is this is a very i think this
is a really difficult position to play
well you're opening them
it's not simple
bishop an h86
it's not my favorite dance but it's fun
but you know i really like this
okay chris tahoe thanks for the prime
no this i like a5
because if you like d5
so now we have knight b6 and then we
have
g5 and then he comes here
oh [ __ ] i didn't see that
whoa okay here no [ __ ] it's bad now
this is really we have to give it to him
i can do something like macarena i mean
i i don't mind dancing
per se and i'm i'm not like
i don't mind the literal
specific act of dancing
it's just sometimes the dances
themselves
would make me shy about it this game is
not totally lost okay we're resigning
1994
we're actually resigning early
f3 was better
now he's gonna take one before
he i don't think he could take his
tactics are so insane it's actually
outside like we can't even give him a
fun advantage yeah but it doesn't but
we should resign i mean
no no that doesn't work because they
don't save the night either they just
give the bishop
okay okay i i need to be a little bit
more careful with the moves you
the suggest was good there i need to be
a little bit more careful
uh but andrea's a good blitz flare so
she's very practical
all right ready yes
king's indian again okay we're just
gonna repeat i mean again they go for
this
c5 is just worse for black i think
no i can't do that i think i can push e5
and knight c6 the idea is e5 so no i
can't that a6 i think is probably a good
move
i think this is the move okay go for it
i don't remember having like this i have
d7 now this one probably c5 that's
that's an interesting idea i've seen
this actually
okay but e5 i take and go f5 like that's
the whole idea of this system
here can we take the pawn here and then
push there
no that's bad okay thank you
cadaver maker for the prime appreciate
it
yeah that's a pretty monkey s name no
landis well
all these latin imposing names thank you
thank you
yes more coffee always helps damn he's
killing us
that is the solution um
[Music]
what about this this and then this but
then they should stamp check here
i i think we have to do that though this
and then we should take with the bishop
what else do we i mean i'm allowed to
look at china
i think i'm doing better looking at the
trap than ignoring it to be honest
c6 here
before he can check us no because we're
still getting mated after he takes
he has to take like this no that loses
too though
everything is lost wow he's killing us
in the opening
this is over okay
just too many threats here we're getting
destroyed it's okay it's done
well yeah i mean being up at seven
the latest frittata is just absolutely
brutal
yeah i take my spot take my spot so you
can play a blizzard yeah this is yours
with me no but
like you can see the difference when i
play actual openings
it's just a completely different okay
sorry i should never have gotten h4
there
tried to sneak a cheap one in and that's
a moment things went wrong
all right ready okay uh let me do this
part
and then you take over the london has
been fine yeah take your time in the
opening
if you get a good opening in time
pressure we can no i'm gonna oh oh he's
doing it okay this is our game
oh it's a similar idea right
it's the same c3 where are we playing
this line it's fine
no i thought it was this and this okay
okay i think you're thinking of a
different line
knight b5 no 935 was idea but he didn't
do it we want to go here and then g5 h5
he played slightly differently um rugby
won
before or joe creative 25 thanks
either or tomorrow is like morning
tonight too
never ends okay so g4 is coming are we
all
do we play knight knight d2 so we don't
allow it
oh wait no then we lose d4
so maybe d5 or takes first yeah we want
to go h5 g4
start attacking on the king's side and
then if he pushes what do we do okay
d5 goes c5 i guess you couldn't push it
okay i'm threatening this one
what about this and if he does this we
run if he does this we want
to see him
oh no oh tomorrow's the inauguration no
no no i see
sorry i thought there was like a
tournament or something open everything
up
i'm out of the loop and it doesn't do
anything though knight b5 has no threat
yes it does it puts pressure here in
here and if he does this then
then what then we play knight here in
here no i'm doing it okay go for it
go further go for it
we have a big threat this which is
winning this ah i love this
that's such an annoying idea but it's
but it's actually okay because i don't i
don't really mind
not having the bishop it's not the end
of the world um
now we need to start pre-moving stuff
half of their time and they've got so
much time it's crazy it's like ticking
ticking thing
never gets never ticks down
at least one gets that sensation i don't
know just putting pressure on them
i need to get them below a minute first
of all
no he takes here i i like maybe queen a1
thank you zorbius for the prime
put the diagonal and then f4 try it
okay proportionally speaking like time
is fine for me
now we got them under a minute finally
i'm wearing the dreamer
is the owner of dream um
so let's go bishop d7 i have this come
on
how do i miss this
okay i still have it they move the rook
from one forkable square to another
now let's go e495 which is a bit risky
because i open up their queen
knight e d5 i was saying that i just
didn't like this
just taken take take the knights take
the ninth
and then fourth on six no because it
takes
it's it's still good you have we're
trading or queen yeah do it you need to
play back oh we can't trade our queen
though
you need to
now it's just like a bullet game i mean
i know it's always the damn fish let's
just sack the queen and go e3 honestly
that's the more practical option i think
okay bishop d3 is not not like a troll
move i was just distracting their queen
all right that's a big win with black
i don't think the future of classical
chess is going to be all draws that's um
that's like baseless thank you also dr
lana for the sub and dc the real
thank you that's a pretty insane you
know i don't think that assumption is a
lot
that was a tough game you know okay we
need a phone is a fair one to make
all right because the draws have been
very combative i mean honestly
it's not like they drew because there's
nothing to play for these games and it's
also the day before the rest day so
it can be easily taken out of context i
don't either
why do you do it then mixing it up
um
good thing we neither of us know what
we're playing and he's playing
almost london yeah i'm doing two more
rounds of commentary now this is the
idea the idea is to go g4 and h4
yeah but this is trouble for black
actually
so see actual theory there is no
tata tomorrow that is arresting stopping
attention i don't think they should
i mean i think they should maybe make
the 30-move draw roll
i don't believe in like taking away the
draw for entirely
i think that's a bit harsh
i honestly think that like hang on hey
russell good to see you but i honestly
think they're like before you have to
give them the pawn then you just can't
take
you know 30 mujararo might be a good
balance that's what they do in the u.s
championship and stuff
bishop b4 is actually kind of a nasty
move here fine queen of six
but then he takes on here is this yeah
[Music]
we're not gonna take
i should have maybe taken on c3 first g5
yeah the wrestling game was this was
fire
yeah oh but he blocked her [ __ ] okay
yep yep
um can you develop the knights
no he's gonna sack on g6 you have to
take the knight no
they can repeat moves but that's less
likely he's taking on e6
and then here no oh my goodness he's
destroying
he is destroying us here
uh yeah sure is he gonna sack
no this is impossible to save wow okay
well it started with a really bad
opening i'd rather play
bad opening distracted like we're we're
just not in it this one
but it's okay thank you seth danson not
quite ted denson with
seth dancing thank you get over before
it's over you're right you're right
you're very right
uh e5 e5 go or here
e5 e5 you're trying no okay b4 is a
thread okay
a7 i don't believe them go here
check and knights and then take the fish
oh
oh dirt
[Music]
um i don't maybe not today brazil
because the commentary is is so
extensive
um unless there's like any specific
moments that people want me to review i
mean i'm happy maybe to do the ferruccia
game
also i'm like i'm pretty oh my god oh
wait wait okay 94 queen e6 thank god
otherwise that was mate okay i'm running
away
oh now they just went to the rook and
it's mate yeah
okay okay okay okay but i'm
pumping you pretty i think you want to
play chess with this playlist
we need something what was that one
what's this sure look at this
how are you gonna put something away
okay
wait put something more upbeat baby i
don't know how many i want in a row
actually
what about jugger yeah no i'd like to no
i won
i think i won six yeah i won six
no no but it was two it was two to one
it was two to one when i lost it was two
to zero then i lost i won
six
all right i need your full focus i'm
very focused you look at chat
it's it's yeah yeah that's right i get
slapped no slap
stop i need four more wins
[Music]
focus okay he's doing the line
and he changed up the line which is what
makes me upset but i remember
this and this was the correct idea there
was also a c3 line but it's not here but
not again
okay then go for it but it didn't work
in the last game
it's fine we just displayed at some
point
i think okay this is an interesting
system that i think
is kind of a good one against the london
and the way that andrea plays it
it's not really double i mean yeah 12 to
1 basically
where are they trying to go i mean i'm
feeling pretty confident this series
it's it's all in the openings i mean
when i get a decent position out of the
opening i'm like totally fine
and i feel very confident in my ability
to win the game when i
screw around in the opening that's when
the problems start
this is kind of a king's indian king's
indian type system
which uh really shuts down white's
counterplay in many instances i guess
let's go here
i'll let them open the b file um
yeah we have this one's good we actually
know cause he plays here okay knight d2
knight c2
okay um this rugby one
yes okay bring him back bring him back
and then cleaning here
yeah i always allow this knife to sex
garbage can you
do sure it's not garbage of course it's
a good move okay
proverbial garbage
that's always the danger he's getting
crushed
yeah bishop h okay they'll of course
find which page five
nope do seven instead i want to go here
okay but the point might be three to
four
wait uh
oh my god that's just stupid oh they
missed it what the hell they admitted
one
queen takes sfa oh that was just dumb
because i expected okay still
freaking losing oh my god
this is still lost though and that's the
problem it's not it's absolutely it
doesn't matter
okay but they lost a piece okay
this is like becoming a okay oh no they
found this
it's an insane tactic yeah and it's lost
they found this at last last idea
how was our time 25 seconds to seven
seconds
no oh of course two seconds
okay save the draw
all right that was insane thank you
bihar for the 14 months
yeah that was okay they need two and a
half so that's a pretty big half point
[Music]
yeah i predicted some of those free
moves like i knew they would promote and
stuff
absolute pure luck and i thought i was
even winning but then they found this
unbelievable tactic
okay yeah
yeah this workout fade is just very
beautiful okay let's go
now let's go i cannot play the ending
okay
and dream wow okay that's very
impressive that's very impressive and
they just outplay outplayed me
completely in this london
but i'll repeat that system i think yeah
we finally got some pumping music that's
what we needed
the music makes this place okay i'm
playing with the king's indian who cares
okay now let's win focus
this is a different version okay we're
just going for it this time
this time i'm going for it this time
this attack is a lot stronger
uh really okay actually takes knight g5
looks okay
knight g5 yeah and h5 because it's just
i think bishop f5 is the only annoying
move
[ __ ] take here
okay yeah and then take the [ __ ] do it
oh i
wow that's an insane move and they found
another insane save yeah
that's just bad this is not bad but it's
unclear
[Music]
and maybe let's try e6 i mean i need to
somehow make inroads into
black's position here uh bishop yeah i
mean
there's definitely some tactics
with the knight yeah but i get half a
point
i get they they have to reach two and a
half points i mean we basically decided
that adoption was
i see that well i mean they won the
first match so i'm just too weak for
adoption
or and they are too strong wait does
that mean no no it's not so i can just
take and this is over
i just promote a bunch of points right
well this is actually not over i don't
know why i said that
yeah they run away
that's mate
i just need to take all the freaking
funds
[Music]
much better okay that was rough that was
rough
probably gonna go knight c4
in either case it should be over ready
i've got plenty of time here
thank you all right i don't know what
they're up to here but
thank you aunt spadaro for the tier one
i think they're going to resign or are
they trying to allow me to sleep
in the game oh [ __ ] we didn't resign oh
that was really bad okay resign that's
good sorry
that was i'm not playing great
oh [ __ ] we have a call in five minutes
i'm not playing great um
[Music]
tbh but it's so far it's much better
than the last game
it's all about those openings no we have
to wait we have five minutes to win this
whole thing
they're getting their lucky hoodies all
right
no no no no they i understand they need
time
zero forty go go go okay they should do
forty there we go
okay let's play a dutch i know this no
end on a dub andrea let's do it
stonewall i don't want to give him any
time to think
maybe that was a mistake it's fine you
could have taken it's okay
knight d2 yeah c3
yep my pawn take the bish no take the
knight
take the [ __ ] take it take the fish and
then
take the knife what about this this okay
this is scary what about this what about
f3
i don't love this position okay that's
fine yeah yeah they know all the
positional ideas
okay no i'm gonna do it
andre it's lost it's actually fine
bishop
chill why is he lost
this one i don't really buy them i think
that was too much
if they go f3 then knight g3 is a fork
that's the idea
now we just step aside we don't want to
go rook g8 because it knight f7
that's one of the key factors here and
then and then maybe we want to open up
the position with cd
because it just got me so excited it
made me feel really strongly bang bang
bang
bang bang okay yeah this is kind of
smothered made but i'd have to give up
my queen which which is very undesirable
alex i need you to play here okay
okay now i can actually play with you
and then i want to go here in knight d7
i need to trade the knights
they're gonna keep here
[Music]
yeah they're so accurate it's like you
you make one little mistake and it's
over yes yes
no it's a fruit pawn
he's thinking what nothing
he's thinking on our time alex we can't
give him any time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stupidest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i mean it's we're not playing an
adoption match though i mean they have
to reach two and a half winners
they have to reach two and a half i have
to reach nine and a half so i need two
more wins they were about to win the
most important match of our life
or three more wins i guess i i think we
should
i think we actually my stupidity has
reached unbelievable
unthinkable levels i think it's two and
a half
i actually do think we should postpone
because there's a team of people waiting
we can't make them wait we can't make
them wait let me call danya let him let
it let me know
just incredible for like a week i've
been playing the right thing
horrible three and a half yeah there's
too many people we can't so let's just
give danya a read
we have to andrea okay okay okay okay
okay okay
okay chad we have a call but we're gonna
finish this we will be back oh they need
three okay but that's
that's fine i mean if i have a little
bit of a question can somebody spam this
chat
oh i have a little they have to go oh
okay
i guess i'll do the dance thing i guess
i'll expect
i don't think it's to him go in his
shower oh there's she's trying to call
me oh crap
wait what i i'm not one sec oh
one sec sorry sorry sorry sorry i didn't
notice it i don't like being late follow
him on discord
let's
[Music]
he doesn't know
call him call him
we have to go no no no no no worries no
no
please go absolutely absolutely no
problem no problem i will do the dance
should i wait for the boat sizes to do
the dance should i wait for you to do
the dance or should i do it
or did you want to watch no no no zero
problems
please have your call i i will be down
to continue later
um call for a sec okay okay
i'm calling
oh my god i'm getting a bonus raid okay
now i should probably do the dance
okay i should definitely do i'm
definitely doing the dance now whoa
alexander thank you so much ladies
oh my god oh my god that scared me so
much
hey we have to go thank you so much for
playing with us we'll resume this yeah
don't do the dance
we're gonna do it once we finish the
match yeah cause we gotta watch and we
totally forgot we have a call with andy
and there's a few people so we don't
want to keep them waiting zero problems
i really appreciate it not not a problem
at all have a great call and thanks for
the match congrats
[Music]
oh my god